well there is a call for swift justice  following the deaths of two young dogs  by dehydration and starvation  police say the 21 year old Blanca fetes  and 22 year old Esmerelda Martinez left  their - 8 month-old pit bulls in a  kennel without enough food and water  supply while they went to Florida they  were gone for nearly three weeks a local  animal welfare group is urging the  district attorney now to prosecute and  sentence those two women officials say  they did not make any attempts to  arrange care for those young dogs while  they were out of state there were so  many choices and they deliberately  denied these dogs any help and this is  one that should actually have the  maximum penalty now Neumann says the  maximum sentence is four years in prison  but as the Martinez are out on bail and  charged with willful malicious torture  of a dog  they're scheduled to return to court  next week